seit einer woche ist das reisen wieder
erlaubt und kroatien dabei bei vielen
deutschen als beliebtes urlaubsziel doch
aufgepasst denn am samstag trieb ein
ungebetener gast vor der küste sein
unwesen
vor dem beliebten copacabana badestrand
im kroatischen dubrovnik wurde ein hai
gesichtet das video was wir hier sehen
können stammt von einer kroatischen
nachrichtenseite und zeigt eine
sichtbare haifischflosse durchs wasser
gleiten die badegäste wurden von der
polizei aufgefordert umgehend das wasser
zu verlassen
zu einer hai attacke kam es
glücklicherweise nicht wie es heißt
könnte es sich um einen blau oder am
markt gehandelt haben die in dieser
gegenden manchmal gesichtet werden